hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gehts was leckeres herzhaftes
ich wache bikini tomaten reis und zwar
ist es was kritisches und es sind so nah
ist auf rebellen mit schafskäse füllung
und dazu gibt's dann eben diesen
typischen griechischen reis in diesem
video heute möchte ich euch jetzt
einfach nur das besteck zeiten also wie
man diese hackbällchen zubereitet und
eben anderen video bekommt ihr das
rezept zum reis und es war übrigens ein
hund rezept von murat denn das ist ja
ganz gerne wenn wir mal beim griechen
sind ich reich dazu später noch ein
bisschen zickig aber zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier 500 gramm hackfleisch das
ist rinde hackfleisch und ich hab mir
sitzt aufgetaut also dass weiden
gefrierfach
dann brauche ich zwei scheiben toastbrot
oder zum beispiel ein altes brötchen
oder altes brot dann habe ich hier die
zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen 1 1
so ein bisschen petersilie habe ich
jetzt auch aus dem gefrierfach von
meinem kräutergarten salz und pfeffer
natürlich habe ich noch etwas oregano
und natürlich schafskäse und später zum
auspacken brauche ich ein bisserl
olivenöl
jetzt bereite ich zuerst die hak masse
zu und nehmen dafür die zwiebel und die
knoblauchzehen und die werden jetzt fein
gewürfelt
dann kommt es mir zum hackfleisch und
ich ziehe mir jetzt einweg handschuhe an
weil ich nicht will dass meine hände
gleich nach knoblauch olaf weber riesen
aber ihr könnt natürlich auch ohne
machen dann nämlich noch das brot und
das wird kurz eingeweicht mit etwas
wasser natürlich keins da auch
semmelbrösel benutzen aber ich finde mit
brot wird es ein bisserl lockerung
ausdrücken
da kommt es auch in so kleinen stückchen
mit dazu
dann noch das ei und die petersilie
jetzt noch gut würzen dann müsst ihr nur
aufpassen der schafskäse ist ja auch
ziemlich salzig und wird sich deswegen
nicht so viel aber trotzdem gut genug
also ein teelöffel salz dürfte ich
erreiche dann kommt noch ordentlich
pfeffer mit rein und wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch kreuzkümmel
mit rein geben oder piment das passt
auch ganz gut
ich lasse es heute aber weg
jetzt fehlt nur noch oregano und da gebe
ich auch einen teelöffel mit rein
und jetzt muss das ganz richtig gut
durchgeknetet werden
und jetzt mache ich immer so kleine
portionen so etwa 80 bis 90 gramm und
die werden dann gleich gefühlt denn käse
habe ich jetzt auch bereits in feine
stifte geschnitten und ein grobes
stifter besser gesagt jetzt habe ich
hier ein stück alufolie und zwar hilft
es einfach beim was nicht danke jetzt
habe ich hier ein stück alufolie und es
hilft einfach beim formen
jetzt breitet es hier ganz flach auf
könnte jede beliebige form machen
ich mache zum kreis daran kommt ein
stück käse rein
die eine hälfte dreht kurz und jetzt
glaube ich dass mit der alu folie zu und
drückten auch die ränder schön fest
dann könnte das einfach schön vorne
ich habe jetzt die ptg geformt und habe
in der zwischenzeit auch noch meinen
reis aufgesetzt dann gibt's nämlich als
beilage und da habe ich ja schon gesagt
da verlinke ich euch dann auch das
rezept in die infobox
und jetzt habe ich hier die fahnder
bereits erhitzt und habe auch olivenöl
mit drin
und jetzt kann ich die bieter reinsetzen
und die werden dann von jeder seite
ungefähr drei bis vier minuten gebraten
die briefe sind jetzt angebraten der
reise ist auch fertig und jetzt mache
ich noch ein bisschen salzig dazu und
später auch noch einen kleinen baum
salat passt nämlich auch perfekt mit zu
dem gericht und für das strategie habe
ich hier bereits joghurt und zwar ist es
ein zehnprozentiger griechischer fester
joghurt das sind so etwa 600 gramm
hier habe ich zwei knoblauchzehen etwas
olivenöl salz pfeffer und etwas
getrocknete minze und es geht jetzt auch
ganz schnell
natürlich könnte man jetzt auch wenn man
möchte mit still abschmecken und pagoden
mit rein geben aber ich möchte sie zeugt
einfach ganz vorhaben sollte
knoblauchzehe die reibe ist herein wenn
sie mit ständig aus der hand rutscht
dann noch ein schluck olivenöl mit rein
natürlich auch salz und pfeffer
und damit unsere
jetzt noch ein bisschen minze mit rein
und dann muss das nur noch abschmecken
ob noch salz und pfeffer fehlt und dann
ist es dass ich fertig der reis die
vicky und dass der sieg ist jetzt fertig
und ich kann das jetzt anrichten und war
richtig den reis vor einem schälchen an
sie müsste form des einfach man kann man
den stufen der gips ab mittags und das
leckere zaziki die element letztlich
auch schon jetzt glaube ich auf hunger
murat wohlig erst darf das jetzt gerne
mal probieren 80 grad heiß
wahrscheinlich zu dem reis reicht man
übrigens auch gern zitronenscheiben nur
als info
zeigt das wichtig
der käse im kreis und käsers dienst
genommen nur ein weichkäse natürlich
fehle jetzt auch der bauernsalat
gigantisch schmeckt wirklich super echt
wie ich klasse kann sich noch immer
zeigt hier gerade hier wirklich super
wirklich klasse mein tor steht ist ja
auch gewünscht und ich denke dass wir
bei unserem griechische freund perfekt
und wenn ihr das gerne auch nach machen
möchtet dann geht einfach auf meinem
blog auffällig ist lochte da stehen noch
mal die genauen mengenangaben und die
zutaten und die zubereitung und wenn es
nach macht freue ich mich natürlich wir
nehmen ein foto auf facebook und auf
instagram schickt also viel spaß beim
nachkochen und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal bis dann doch zu allem